その八つの順番では 一番目はすごく力が強い
番目はわずかに力 わずかに弱いですけど
その八つのリストの中で智慧入っている心は四つあります
智慧が入っている心四つはものすごく力が強い
智慧が入ってない心の四つはそれほど力がない
わずかに力が弱い 智慧が入っている四つの中でも奇偶でアサンカーリカだったら力強いとかは言えます
でも一番大事なポイントは智慧があるかないかというとこだけなんです
その生まれた心に智慧という身性があったかないか
そこでも智慧っていうのは
仏教で言ってる悟りの智慧とかね
そんなもう大胆なものではないんです
ただ 物事をきちんと理解できるような心で
いいカルマをしたら 例えば人にお金をあげて助けてあげると
でもやむを得なかったんだからとかね
みんなやってるんだからとか
そういう嫌なことやもうなというふうなことでやっちゃうと
そこに智慧が働いてないんですね
そうじゃなくて やっぱりいいことをするべきですよと
という自分の意思で いいことだから私はやりますよと
どうせ人間に生まれたんだから
人間は何かいいことをして残っておかなくちゃいけないんだと
それぐらいの でも明るさ
そのぐらいの智慧でいいんです
いいことをしたらいい結果になるんではないかと
悪い結果には決してならない
だから私はその人を助けてあげるんだというふうな
この自分の意思で 自分で考えて
ちゃんと物事を理解して
いいことをすると そこに智慧が入ってるんです
例えば誰かがタレントさんが来て募金すると活動をやっちゃうと
みんなお金ものすごい入りますけど
その場合はその人と握手できるんだからとかね
それぐらいだったらもういくらでも払うと
っていう場合は智慧は働いてないんですね
ただ欲だけ働いてるんですね
千円の寄付したらもう握手してくれませんと
1万円寄付したら その人は自分でちゃんとこのタレントさんが握手してくれるんだと言ったら
みんなもう 1万円札持って行ってもう並んじゃうでしょうし
その時の活動は募金活動かもしれませんし
どうかのね 病気の子どもたちを助けようとかなんとかとかね
飢えている人々を助けようとか
そういうすごい立派な活動かもしれませんだけど
活動自体は でもカルマを行うのは個人だから
1万円投げた寄付した人がの心に智慧があったかないかっていうことは
もう問題なんです そこで仏教の世界でよく言うのは
ちゃんと物事を理解して行動しなさいと
ただみんながやるんだからとか
そういうもういい加減なヘリックスは使うなと
ヘリックスでもあろうと
いいことはいい結果なんですよ
それは別に問題ないんだけど
せっかくいいことをするならば
きちんと理解して 自分の意思で自分で責任を持ってやればいいんじゃないかと
だからタレントさんが来て募金活動するとお金払ってもいいんだよ
その時はこの人が来ているんだからではなくて
その人々が来てそういうことを作ってくれたことはありがたいのではないかと
それで私にも寄付できたんだと
それできちんとその人々にお金行くだろうと
それはいいことだから
じゃあぜひやりますという気持ちでやれば
そこの中では自分の智慧が働くんです
だから世の中で智慧を働かせていいことをさせるのはなかなか難しいんです
人を騙さないといいことはしないんですよ
だから世の中で人間っていうのは無意識的に知ってますよ
このいくら宗教神様だあれこと言っても
どんな生命 無意識的に知ってるんですよ
自分がやっぱり自分を行う出来事によって
自分の寿命のもう幸福不服決まってるんだと
それはもう無意識に刷り込まれてる真実だからね
そんななんか変な宗教が出てきて
何か嘘を言っても それはもう変えられません
ですから このヘンテコリンなことを信仰してる人々は
みんな心の中でどこかでちょっとした不安というか
何か納得いかないとことかいっぱい持ってる
それは我々にとってはしょうがないことなんですけど
で ですからこの人はいいことをするべきですよということは
もう当たり前の心理になってるんです
だからどんな宗教でもいいことをしよう
いいことをしようということは言ってるんです
言ってるんだけど やってくれない
それでまた人を騙す いろんなことをしちゃうんですね
だから宗教と関係なく
こういうね まあボランティア活動やら募金活動やらする場合は
ほとんど有名なタレントの人々やら
まあ有名な人々やら出てきて
たまにね 音楽歌ったりとかね
やったりするでしょうね
それでいろんな歌手たちが来て
ボランティアで歌ってくれる
その場では普通には全然集まらない立派な人々
たくさんタレントさんたちが集まるでしょうね
普通 お金払って集まろうと思ったら
これなかなかできない
みんな自分で無料で歌ってあげることだから
なんとなく気持ちよく行って歌ったりする
で 私もそういう歌をいくつか聞いたんだけど
やっぱり同じ歌 お金取って歌うよりは
なんとなく感情というか
フィーリングというか
それすっごく強いんです
インパクトが なんかすごく美しく綺麗に聞こえるんです
その人はその時歌うのはお金もらうんだからっていう目的じゃなくて
やっぱり自分がこういう人々を助けるために歌ってるんだと
自分の能力を使ってるんだっていうことでやってるんだから
歌としても感じがすごくいいし
聞いてる人々にとってもすごいノーハッタンで
普通だったらそれぐらいのたくさんタレントさんが 1箇所にまとめませんだから
ですから そういう何か催し物なんか作ったら
ものすごい大金が集まっちゃうんです
でも カルマの立場から見れば
そこは人を騙してることなんですよ
人は歌を歌を聞きたい
タレントさんの顔を見たい
楽しみたいという欲望を持っていて
それにそういう場を与えてくれる
そこで人の心にあるのは
いろんな音楽を聴くことだけなんです
いろんなタレントさんの顔を見ることだけなんです
で そこで金を集めてしまう
だから これはもう人間の欲の働きですから
どうしようもないんですよ
欲の働きだから せっかくのいいことも知恵を持ってすることはできないんです
知恵を働かすことはできないんです
だから そういうシステムは世の中になくてはならないシステムになっているわけです
そうでないと人は全然いいことはしないんですよ
いいことをしないと この世の中が生きていられなくなっちゃうんです
平和が消えちゃうんです
だから我々は幸福で平和で生きているのは
どんな形 どうであろうか
人がいいことをしているんだからなんです
みんなそれなりに ですから
どんな宗教でも この社会に大変この社会を平和で維持するために大変な大事な役割を果たしているんです
宗教を捨てちゃったら
もう人間自分だけ儲ければいいということになってしまうんです
そうするとあまり長い時間は儲からないんです
自己破壊になっちゃうんです
今のエコロジーの問題であろうがね
地球の問題であろうが
全部できたのは欲だけで行動したんだからなんです
これは昔ながら 我々はこの山は神様がいるんだからありがたいとかね
川は大変尊い ありがたい神様が宿っているんだとか
そういう原始的な概念であろうともあった
ならば 我々は山を大事にする
木を大事にする 川を大事にする
水を大事にする 無茶に使わない
それだったら長生きできるようになっちゃうし
ですから やっぱり宗教の宗教
すべての宗教はね 特別な宗教ではなくて
人間のために大変なもう必要なメッセージを確実にそれだけは言っているんです
だからずっと叩かれるのも宗教なんですね
世の中で嫌がるのも宗教なんですけど
でも人に生きるために必要な命の泉になっているのは
そういう宗教なんです
それはどんな原始的な宗教であろうか
その仕事をやってるんです
人に生きるために必要な生命の泉ですね
そのエネルギーを与えてくれるんです
それ取っちゃったらどうしようもなくなっちゃう
共産主義の時代というソ連の中で
人々は隠れて隠れて教会に行ったりしたり
拝んだりしたりしてたんだから
中国でも そこはもう捨てることはできないんです
共産主義的な唯物論で理解できる世界じゃないんです
唯物論というのはものすごい不完全な教えで
まるっきりもう馬鹿げた教えで
体だけで物質だけでもの動くわけじゃないんだけどね
目に見える心を否定するんだから
ぶん殴ったら痛いということは
その馬鹿が知ってるのに
人にぶん殴って痛くなったら怒ることは知ってるのに
心を否定してるんですよ
ですから それはもう全くもういい加減な哲学でしたけどね
それでもやっぱり人間に何らか
何か心の支えとかね 何かいいことをして
それから得られる喜びとかね
そういうのは必要なんです
本当に心はそれで動いてるんですよ
人間の幸福っていうのは
確実に人間がやっていいことから生まれてくるものなんです
ですから 善行為をするべきですよというのは
これは当たり前の現象で
もう論外なんですよ 人は呼吸するべきですよということと同じことなんです
人は呼吸しなきゃ死ぬでしょうし
それは体は死ぬんだけど
いいことをしなきゃ心がものすごいひどい目に遭うんですよ
ですから それは基本的な事実
だからもう宗教哲学に合わないにも関わらず
いいことをしようと言ってるんですよ
例えばキリスト教だったら
イスラム教だったら もう絶対神を信じているし
神様が自分勝手に自分の希望で人間創ったんだから
目的は何ですかと神様を褒めることだよ
それだったら思いっきり神様を褒めちゃえばいいのに
やっぱりいいことをしなさいと一元的に言ってるんです
なんでいいことをしなくちゃいけないかと
説明はないんです やっぱりそれ捨てることはできないんです
だからそのイスラム教にしたっても
自分持ってる全ての財産の2.5%ぐらいかな
1年に一回寄付しなくちゃいけないんです
1年に一回  1ヶ月間ずっと断食して
お祈りしたり 心清らかにして欲を捨てて行動しなくちゃいけないんです
この 1ヶ月間の断食期間では
もう男女関係も何もなく
みんなもうできるだけ心を戒めるんです
なんでそんなことしなくちゃいけないんですかね？絶対的な神様が自分を創ってくれたんだから
わざわざそんなくだらないことをやらなくたっても
神様は助けてくれるはずでしょうし
なんであんなことしなかったら神様に助けられないんですかね？神様が弱いですかね
と聞きたくなるんですよ
神様弱いですか？と言ったら怒られて殺されるかもしれませんだけど
弱くないんですよと だったらなんで私は断食しなくちゃいけないんですか？と
やっぱりその時はやっぱりこの心の法則はもう働いてるんですよ
いいことをしなきゃ心は良くならないんだと
心が良くならないということは
生命として幸福にならないということなんです
キリスト教でも世の中でいること
いるのはいいことをしてるんだからでしょうに
そうでなくて生きていられないんです
病院作ったり いろんなところに行って人を助けてあげたり
もうありとあらゆる福祉活動をしていて
それでありがたい教えだとみんな思っちゃうんです
だから事実はやっぱりいいことするべきことは必要であるということなんです
ありがたいと思う ここは神様がいてもいなくても
みんな言ってくれるんです
マザーテレサみたいに神様を信じてやっても
まるっきり信じないで
それでも同じ行動をやったならば
もっと褒めてくれる可能性もあったんですよ
どんな宗教でも関係なく
その人はいいことをしているんだと
[背景音楽]まあそういうことで人間はいいことをするべきですっていうことは
まあそれで置いておいて
いいことをするときは
もう仏教で言うならもうちょっとプラスアルファで
その法則を理解してやりなさい
それだけ 神に脅され 脅かされてとかね
タレントさんに惑わされてとかね
そういうくだらないことではなくて
この心の法則を理解してやりなさいと
そうするとそれは智慧というんです
ですから 世の智慧とは次元が違うかもしれません
それはカルマの働き 知っている智慧と呼ばれている
だからカルマの働き 知っていることにも智慧というし
無常であることをわかることにも智慧というわけ
そういうことで いいことをすると
やはり智慧を持つ智慧に基づいて
智慧と一緒にいいことをすると
それとの力がすごい すごい
ものすごい結果が強いんです
それで この八つの この大意熟心の八つの中で智慧が入っている心 四つがありまして
その心は力強くて 智慧が入ってない心はそれほど力ないです
それで 世の中の人々がいいことをする場合は
智慧使う確率が高いか
使わない確率が高いかと聞いたら
どちらの方でしょうか
ほとんど使わないんですね
智慧を 世の中にいいことをする人々は少ないんです
きちんと智慧を使って
この心の法則をわかって
カルマの法則をわかってやる人々っていうのはものすごい少ない
ですから 世の中で我々人間で生まれたでしょうに
人間に生まれた時はどんな心で生まれたんですかというと
もうはっきりとこの八つの心の中で一つで生まれたんです
もしその中で智慧遭遇の心で生まれたならば
その人はものすごい人
その人は人間の中で特別に光を輝いているんです
でも少ないです そういう人々っていうのは
すごい ものすごい心が広くて
もういわゆる人格があって
人間には忘れがたい存在でいて消える人々っていうのは少ない
それ簡単なことなんですよ
我々何かいいことをすると
いつでもいいことをしているんだから
いつでもやるいいことをちょっと智慧を使ってやればいいんですよ
それだけのことでどれほどの差が生まれるかというと
そこで瞑想の世界で瞑想は確実に成功するのはこの智慧を
智慧があって生まれた人々なんだそうです
これを三因の生まれと言うんですよ
いわゆる布団布陣プチ
この三つの入っている心布団布陣プチ
この三人の心で生まれている人は
まあ瞑想しようとだったらもう何のことなくすぐすぐもう成功してしまうんです
人で生まれた人々は まあかなり苦労しなきゃもう見かけないわけです
じゃあ一応この八つの心も結晶の働きをする
新しい場所に生まれる時は
その八つの心で生まれる
この八つの心はどこに生まれるかというと
人間の世界と神々の世界
それからこの三十三ページからこの欲海色界心が出てくるんですね
色界心の意熟心があるんですね
三十四ページに入ってるんです
この三十四ページの二十二番目
意熟心五つですね それは色界心
色界心っていうのは この瞑想して戦場を作った人の心なんですね
瞑想して戦場を作った人が生まれ変わる時は
この色界心の意熟心で生まれるんです
生まれる場所は梵天なんです
人間で生まれません だからこの色界心の意熟心で生まれた人間は一人もいません
我々は大意熟心で生まれているんです
それでそれ一つですね
それで無色界の意熟心は四つあるんです
それは三十七ページの二十七番目
で さらに瞑想すると 無色界の戦場を作ることはできるんですね
無色界の戦場を作った人が亡くなったら
無色界の意熟心 四つありますから
そのふさわしい心で生まれるんですね
それも無色界という梵天なんです
生まれる場所も決まってるんです
それで で それから七五ページに行きましょう
で この七五ページにこのウペッカー
あの斜行の二つの水道心っていうのは
この前言ったこと言ったことと
八大の熟心も説明しましたし
それから九つの色無色界の意熟心
意熟心 その量なんですね
その心は結晶とウブンと死の作用するんだと
これ大変なこの考え方なんですよ
生命の生まれる心 死ぬ心と
それから何も認識しないと
この命をつなげてくれる心
この三つの働きやってる心は全部そこで言ってるんです
いわゆる水道心二つと大意熟心八と九つの内心
大色界無色界の意熟心です
それで大体分かりやすいんですよ
生命ってどういうものかということを
そういう風に小さくしてみちゃうと
そこでこの水道心 意熟心
ああだこうだと言うと分からないかもしれませんだけど
それは大したことないんです
心は一つですから その時心に入るこの心想によって心の名前が変わるだけなんです
水道心にはほとんど心象がもうないんです
あの決まってる基本的な心象しかないんです
そこで意熟 大意熟心の場合は
やっぱり布団布陣地の働きがありますから
かなり心象の先心象が二十五もうどっと入って入りますから
明るい心とかたくさん心象が入ってるんです
だから心象の量が多い
それだけのこと だから水道心で生まれた人の基本的な心はすごく弱い
人間の心の場合は先心だから
たくさん心象が入ってるんだからかなり強い
人間と神々はそこで梵天になっちゃうと
もう戦場も作ってるんだから
ものすごい心は強いんです
で 一人の生命が一つの川に例えてみると
川がそのその場所によってゆっくり流れる
ものすごい暴流になるとかあるでしょうに
例えば水の量が多くなっちゃうとものすごい危なくて
強烈に流れちゃうし 崖の方がすごい高かったらもうすごい大きな滝になっちゃうし
そこでダムなんか作ってしまえば
そこでものすごい大きな湖になってしまったりするし
ダムの中からこの水力発電に水が行くところになってくると
すごい強烈でしょうし
そういうふうな感じで
その環境によって流れている水という川の状態が変わると
ですから我々も戦場なんか作ったら
その心はすごく強烈で強いんですね
で それは自分が得たカルマなんですね
戦場を作ったら それが一つのカルマなんです
戦行為なんです そこであまりにも強烈な戦行為をしたんだから
その人が死ぬ瞬間 死ぬ時は死んじゃいますけど
普通の心で 決勝心はあの偉大なあの戦行為の心が次の決勝心を決めてくれる
ですから 人間では弱かったかもしれませんだけど
その人間が戦場を作ったならば
次に生まれる時はものすごい高い次元で力強く生まれちゃうんです
人間にすごい立派な人で生まれても
何のいいこともしなかった人だったら
悪いことばっかりした人が
まあ死ぬ時は死んじゃいますけど
同じ心で堂々と力強く死にますけど
何もいいことしてないんだから
次の決勝心はものすごく弱くなってしまうんです
それで次に理解してほしいのは
一つの生命の中で 決勝心も有分心も死心も全く同じです
それはすごく覚えておいてください
その中にもすごい哲学が入ってるわけです
決勝心も有分心も死心も全く同じ
同じ心 そういうことはこういうこと
例えば不善 成熟心の遮後随動心で生命が生まれたとする
どうせ人間ではないんですね
その人が その生命の有分心も随動心なんです
同じ遮後の随動心なんです
その生命の死心も同じく遮後の随動心なんです
例えば私はこの第八心の中で番目の心で生まれたとする
そうすると私の有分心も番目の心
私の死心も番目の心 同じ心ですけど
働きは違うんですね 生まれて生まれる働きもあるし
死ぬ働きがあるし つなげてくれる働きであるし
で あの話が難しくなるのは
今これからはもうどんどん専門用語を使わないと説明しにくいんです
だから専門用語をかなり覚えていただいて
だろうと思ってるんだから
このリストも覚えてないし
だから心象のリストも覚えてないし
ですからなかなか説明しづらいんです
初めは説明できたんだけど
これからはもっとすごい違う哲学的なことやいろんなことを言わなくちゃいけないのが
言う時は 僕にとっては決勝分子心理一つだよというだけで
なぜ一つにそうなるかということを説明して
それこそできればありがたいんだけどね
いわゆる一旦生まれたら
もうその心で死ぬまで頑張らなくちゃいけないということなんですね
だからかなり制限されてるんですよ
それはカルマなんです
だから生まれた心というのをカルマの結果でしょ
それから何を見ようと何を勉強しようと
元の心が変わってくることだから
で あまり変わらないとね
いわゆるこの材料を通せ
人に何かいくらかの材料をあげて
例えば金いくらかあげると
その金を持っていろんなことをしてくださいと
言ったら その人 その金で何かアクセサリー作ってももう決まってるんですね
量は もしもう何て言いますか
耳に耳飾りですか もうイヤリング 2つぐらい作れるぐらいの金だったら
それでネックレスは作れませんし
それでもやっぱりネックレスは作りたいんだと思ったら
ものすごい薄い チェーンでネックレスを作るしかないんです
そこでこれを売って 何か他の必要なものを買いましょうと思ったっても
もう決まってるんです
その金を売って土地買うこと
家買うことはできないんです
もしかするとテレビ 1台も買えない
だからもう基本的なエネルギーで
その人の行動パターンのこの一生の中で決めちゃうんです
それで知恵を使ってくださいと後に入れてくる
入れると その人がもしかすると
そのネックレスじゃなくてイヤリングは作られる
それで OK のネックレスを作っちゃったらものにならないんです
イヤリング作れるんだからイヤリングを作るんだ
それを丁寧に作って 作ったところでイヤリングを売っちゃう
イヤリング売っちゃったら
金よりはいくらかお金が入ったりする
そのお金を持ってまた頭を使って行動すると
もっと財産が増える可能性はあるんですね
それは善行為の働きで
持って生まれた能力はないと泣くんじゃなくて
それは自由に使ってみたら
もうかなりの人間として成長することはできるんです
で それでもいろいろ制限があることは確かにあるんです
初めから 1億円でスタートする人と 1万円でスタートする人の
やっぱり道が違いますからね
心の場合はもっともっとコントロールされるんですよ
例えば私が私の結晶心がありますね
それで結晶心は一回しか生まれませんだけど
それからずっと分身なんですけど
私にいつでも分身があるんです
私は何か考えようとする瞬間
考える前に分身なんですよ
分身がなくなって考える心が生まれるんです
分身の代わりに ですから
考える量はもうほとんど決まっている
見る時も同じで 聞く時も同じです
行動する時でも同じで
いつでも分身があって
分身が消えて 行動の心が生まれる
それで行動が終わったら
また心が止まって分身になる
なって 次にまた新しい行動をするという
このコンピュータープログラムと同じプログラムでもう働いているので
そこら辺は後の説明があります
明確な心のプログラム
どのようにプログラムかと
コンピューターの場合も
いつでもコンピューターの性能というのは使っている OS によって決められるんです
オペレーティングシステムというコンピューターを動かす基本的なプログラムがあります
それは使っている人によっては関係ないんです
見えない世界だから でもそれでコンピューターの性能はもう全部コントロールされるんです
だからどんな性能を使ってもらう
どんな仕事をさせてもらっても
結局 OS がもう OSが許してくれるならばできるし OS
システムがダメというならばダメなんです
そういうことで そのその生命に生命の行動をカルマでコントロールされているんです
そういうわけで 我々はどう頑張っても猫には算数なんか教えることはできないんです
どう頑張っても猿に言葉を教えをあげることとかいろいろ頑張ってるでしょうに
でもコントロールされてるんです
決まってる それはもうその壁を破れないんです
同じく我々はこの仏教の話聞いたり
いろんな宗教の話聞いたりしてね
まあ幽霊があるんだとかね
神々がいるんだとか 天国はあるんだとかね
極楽があるんだとか 聞いてはいるんだけど
見たことはないでしょう
どう頑張っても人間に見られない異次元的な世界は見られない
体験できないんです コントロールされてるんです
人間に聞こえる音はもうコントロールされてる
それ以上の音は聞こえないんです
見えるものもコントロールされてるんです
それは全部カルマなんです
カルマはわからないと言っても
もうすでにカルマの中で業の中で行動してるんですよ
見るもの 聞くもの 味わうもの
食べるもの 食べ物の好き嫌い
自分の性格 自分 付き合ってる人々は頭で全てこのカルマに
自分のカルマでコントロールされてるんです
そこを見ると自分のパターンがわかるんですよ
だから まあ一応 15歳ぐらいまで 20歳ぐらい生きていれば
自分がどんなパターンで生きてきたんですか？そのパターン見ちゃえば
まあそれで自分なんですよ
死ぬまで 明日はあるんだと思ったって明日はないんです
で そこら辺は説明するために
アビダンマでこういうこういうことを分析しているんです
そういうアビダンマ的な立場でないと理解できないんです
カルマの 普通の人はカルマのこと教えてくれったって教えない方がいいもの事って教えるなんてわからないんで
そんなの それは心の働きを徹底的に理解しておかないと
カルマの複雑な行動はわからないんです
そこでアワッジーナ・キッチャーニ・パナ・ドゥエッという言葉なんですけど
このテキストに19書いてます 19
のところで我々の結晶決まってるんですね
生命の そこでアワ 切っちゃってる働きがあるんですね
それは因典の作用 これもなんか仏教すごく気になることなんですよ
因典というのはあわっちょるっていうパーリ語はあわっちょるなんですけど
で あのまあ不思議なもの
コンピューターの CPU の働きと似てるんですけどね
まあそこら辺わからないと説明しちゃっても意味がないんだからやめますけど
この心 例えば我々が寝ていても起きるでしょ
なんで起きるんですかね
寝ていると見えないし
聞こえないし 体触ってもわからないし
でも起きてしまうんですよ
起きなかった人は一旦寝たらそのまま死んじゃうんですけどね
起きられませんから 不思議に起きるんですね
それがこの心 分身という心が
なんか情報ないかなっていう
なんか情報あったら取るぞという状態にいるんですね
情報ないと寝るんだけど
情報があったらすぐ起きるんです
その起きる心がこの慰問点なんです
何ですか 因点です で あのコンピューターの CPU を設計した時も同じく
この一つの仕事をするしかしませんだけど
CPU も でもいつでも一つの仕事をしながら
ものすごい早いんだからね
もう CPU ものすごい早いです
どこから情報入ってるかなとちょっとチェックするんですね
キーボードからでも情報来るかなとかね
あるいはプリンターから情報来るかなとか
何か機械から情報来るかないかっていうことを
いつでもこの働いている途中で
そこら辺もちょっとちょっと見てみるんですよ
あれを読んだところで
なんかこの心の働きと同じ働きだなと思ったんだけど
私が そのためにコンピューターの CPU の働きができるだけ早くしちゃう
そうすると我々に早く仕事をできる
ですから コンピューターが一つの仕事をしていても
キーボードの命令を受ける状態のプログラムだったら
キーボードで命令を打った瞬間
すぐそれを受け取って
その働きに自分の働きを変えてしまう
ゲームなんかやってると
ゲームで画面でいろいろ敵が出て
敵が追ったりするでしょうに
だから画面にいろんな敵を出したり
計算したりするのは仕事なんですけど
キーボードから何が入ったらすぐそこを計算して
その代わりに敵を動かしたり
なんとかしたりしてくれるんですね
我々の心もいつでもどこかから情報が入るかなという状態があるんです
その状態は 2つに分けてあって
一つは御門因典と言うし
もう一つは慰問因典と言うんです
御門因典というのは この眼耳鼻舌身から情報が入ると
それを受ける心 慰問因典というのは
頭の中で意識で何か概念が生まれると
それを受ける心 で それはもっとわかりやすくするとこういうことなんだ
わかりやすくするとわからなくなるかもしれませんだけど
分身が 分身が消えちゃって
御門因典が生まれたら
見たり聞いたり何かする
慰問因典生まれたら考えたりする
で 何が生まれるかというと
そこはまたわからないところなんですけどね
分身っていうのは寝ている心だから
寝ている心が すぐ何をやるでしょうかと思ったら
ほとんど慰問ですね ですから
寝ている人も何か夢見てそれから起きるんだから
だから妄想の方がすごい強烈で
もう出来やすいんです
耳で音を聞くよりも 目で物を見るよりも
妄想することはやりやすいんです
慰問因典はどちらかというと起こりやすいんですが
それはもう阿比達マテキストではそう書いてないんです
私の 私の意見ですけど
そこでどのどんな時慰問因典生まれるかというと
やっぱり阿比達マの説明はちょっと足らないかもしれませんだけど
外にいろいろ情報があってね
情報体に触れると もう寝ていられない
だからそこら辺に目が覚める
人が寝ていると 誰か名前で呼ぶと
呼ぶ声がすごい強烈なんですね
そこで人間の耳っていうのは
音を受けて物質的な変化するようになってるんですね
だから人は寝ていても寝ていなくても
耳が物質変化しちゃうんです
物質変化しちゃうと 心にはなかなか寝ていられなくなっちゃう
それに反応しなくて それで